I had the idea of doing a sort of an
opening bird of reverse words like the
donnager spells but it's too much work
so Justice League dark it has been a
while since I have come back to DC
animated films and they have been up and
down a bit recently basically the short
version is the ones that have been best
in the last three years or so have been
the ones devoid from the new 52 based
continuity that they did so you know
things like son of Batman throne of
Atlantis Justice League war all those
interconnected ones I have really hated
and not to say that everything that was
divorcee I liked Killing Joke had
problems but mostly ones that weren't
part of that have been good I liked
assault on Arkham gods and monsters
returned another kid Crusaders
so this Justice League dark I was I was
nervous about but I was still kind of
hopeful for because I knew even though
it was part of that continuity that I
don't like it was not involving you know
these versions of the Justice League
that I don't like at all
so knowing that it was focusing on other
characters I thought maybe it'll still
work that was part of how Batman bad
blood actually kind of worked because it
wasn't dealing with Batman himself very
much and yeah that's pretty much the
case I was pleasantly surprised by this
it was kind of a relief i-i-i miss
enjoying these movies so this was this
was good for me I had a lot of fun with
this I don't know a lot of these
characters particularly deeply but I do
have a surface level knowledge of a lot
of them and I like a lot of them I like
Constantine I love that they got Matt
Ryan back to do it again because I'd
like to the Constantine TV show I wasn't
in love with it but I liked it I was
sorry to see a go after only one season
so it's nice to get him back a fun fact
the guy who voiced Ritchie also reprised
roll from the TV show I on that note I
almost kind of wish they could have
brought back the guy who played Felix
Faust on the TV show but to be fair this
version of Felix Klaus is way different
than he was in the TV show you're from
the ground up at the character so yes
that's fine so you know the other
characters we got cetana we got Swamp
Thing we got dead man we got this weird
thing a black orchid I got I got to look
that up and see if that take on black
orchid is completely original or has
some basis somewhere that I just missed
so we've got all these magic users and
then there's Batman thrown in the mix
and that I thought it was really nervous
about I am I have not been a huge fan of
Jason O'Mara has Batman but you know
what they found the perfect way to use
him in this story there's actually a
recurring gag and I loved it which was
that you know something insane would
happen and badly we just kind of stand
there and go ahead back I laughed
every time even when I saw it coming I
laugh that was great and that was a
really good use for Batman most of the
rest of the Justice League cameo
appearances at best and that's good as
far as going to Circus as I said not a
big fan of how they've been depicted in
these movies thus far now I probably am
going to get into spoilers a little bit
I'll try and hold back and not get into
it too much so there's all the
characters I mentioned there's a few
others in there as well we've got the
demon which means we've got Jason blood
who has a great line and I think the
perfect description of John Constantine
describes him as the man who perfected
the bad idea that's great I love that so
we get um you know some background on
some of these characters others not so
much
I think we got maybe a little more
background that was needed on some of
them so like we get some of the demons
background in history and how he got a
link to Jason blood and that makes sense
because there's aspects of that story
that tie into other stuff going on so
that that works okay I don't know why we
got a detailed description of Boston
brand and dead man's origin and all that
note I think dead man's kind of the dead
weight here he's not useless in terms of
a story function he just he didn't
really work for me the accents were
really overblown
I think I think they try to make him
intentionally irritating but that's
always a slippery slope because it's
really hard to make a character who's
irritating to the other characters
without having them also be irritating
to the audience and do the guy's a
little grading and this thing is also
very action heavy now that's been a
point of criticism by me for a lot of
these movies recently but it's different
here because the reason I've criticized
the action heavy stuff before in
something like Justice League war and
certainly the more grounded stuff like
Batman versus Robin is that it was
boring it was just punching and when
you're doing animation I must tell me
more ventus than that you get a bunch of
magic users doing these insane things
and yes the action is fun and exciting
and inventive and that makes it
enjoyable that makes it visually
exciting and even though there's a
couple of the action beaten like that
was unnecessary I wasn't overly normally
because we're still interesting to watch
so all that work the the imagery for the
demons was really good it was really
creepy I think you can probably pick up
the notes of where the story is going
and there's a little bit of mystery
involved that it's not that hard to
figure out or call either so I'm not
sure the story is quite as clever as it
thinks it is but and the story isn't
necessary I would have liked something a
little bit more
I don't know unexpected twisty
what-have-you but the story was solid
enough that allowed the other stuff like
the good voice casting like the
inventive action to shine the way that
it needed to shine I'm again this thing
isn't perfect it's not upper echelon but
certainly for the recent output that the
DC animated films have been giving us
this was a good solid time I had a lot
of fun with it and I wasn't sure that I
was going to so this was a relief and I
wish I could say that it means I'm going
to be hopeful for the Teen Titans Judas
contract unfortunately I'm not because I
hate kV his Wayne and Batman so so much
yeah I can't bring myself to be hopeful
for that but I'm still going to check it
out be wanting
surrounded to it obviously this this
film has been out for a little while it
took me a while to get to it but I'm
happy to have watched it I enjoyed it it
it reminds me that you know not
everything is going to be as brilliant
as gods and monsters was which was
awesome but it's just nice to have to
feel like the baseline like this is this
is your standard I just wanted to get
raised again because this feels about on
par with something like Justice League
doom or maybe even the flashpoint
paradox maybe a little bit below that
one but it feels more akin to that then
you know the recent DC output so good
stuff I enjoyed it have you seen Justice
League dark what were your thoughts on
it whatever they were drop something
down in the comments and let's talk
about it don't forget to Like subscribe
check me out on Twitter right counselor
geeks give a listen to the council of
geeks or the punch like a girl podcast
both available on iTunes and stitcher
and until next time this council is
adjourned
[Applause]